what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time that's
right well while she's trying to get
rich wrestlers just trying to get our
lunch money right i'm here with the
beautiful intelligent
in uniform playing the evil over
marinova popular p-a-m-p
don't forget that lunch buddies not
sponsored by block fight if you don't
have a block fight account at this point
you're a loser
i'm kidding you're not a loser but go
get a black fight account go to block
fight.com
you can earn up to 8.6 apy in an
interest bearing account
that's right eight point six percent apy
in the interest bearing account
go get a block by account i'm an
investor i'm a happy user you'll be a
happy user too if you go get a block fi
account blackfy.com turning it over to
you
okay so um that was weird so i
yeah so i've read this report or i read
this article that's citing this report
and it's saying that um economic data
out of the united states is looking
increasingly promising the services pmi
from the institute of
for supply management which uses surveys
to track
economic activity in the sector stop
scratching your hand
it's so loud who knew that hand
scratching could be so loud okay
so this institute just posted its
highest reading in almost two years
like what does that mean apparently the
chair of the survey committee said it
was a good
report we should see a good first half
of the year and a better second half
things are looking more optimistic i
don't see no data here
then it says the news comes after the
congressional budget office said
that america's real gross domestic
product the broadest measure of economic
activity
will grow at a pace of 4.6 in 2021
by that forecast the economy will be
back to its pre-pandemic size
by the middle of the year listen i ain't
listening to this nonsense
i don't believe none of this what i do
know is personal income
uh what i do know is savings rate up
what i do know is housing prices
up what i do know is bitcoin price up
what i do know is the stock market
up you know why ain't got nothing to do
with real economic
data has everything to do with these
people are out here and they're just
gonna
and print and print and print
and they're gonna print it all and
they're gonna print it off do you see
how i went from a low-grade printer
to a high-grade printer you know why
because they're just warming them up and
they're printed more and more and more
and they're injecting it all into the
economy and asset prices are going
through the roof and these idiots are
all saying oh the economy's getting
better no it's not
all the businesses are going out of
business because you fools all shut down
the economy once you open back up the
economy
get the vaccines in people's freaking
arms and then let us all
go back to living our lives but no now
they're talking about digital passports
and nonsense where you're literally
going to have to show
a thing get in that of a country how
about you as a government stop trying to
surveil us
and let us just go live our lives we
don't want to be dependent on you
why are you trying to weaken us why are
you trying to make us dependent on you
we don't need you we can live our own
lives so just let us live our lives open
the economy stop with the stupid rules
get the vaccines in people's arms
and leave us alone wow
i'm on one today trillionaire energy
times a thousand
i don't even know that's a big ass
number he's he's playing with the pen
that my mom got him for christmas it's
gold plated because i need to sign
anything
okay hubspot a publicly traded
company is acquiring the hustle
sam the deal's expected to close next
week uh the terms i don't think were
disclosed
he got paid my guys got paid according
to axios the deal is valued at roughly
27 million dollars
sam got paid i know sam got paid sammy's
and he's no dummy
he's not signing the deal unless sam got
paid sam
i appreciate you i hope you got paid
next time i see you mcdonald's on you my
friend oh
guys today i got really hungry and i
ordered mcdonald's like how embarrassing
is that not only
i stooped to the level where i i could i
didn't even walk to get it was
it's okay sam don't think we forgot
about you next time we see you
if you need go sign up for the hustle
it's great they send the email you learn
a bunch of stuff they're funny sometimes
if sam writes that it's not funny but if
anybody else writes it it's funny
but sam definitely got can we just talk
about beyond sam getting paid can we
just talk about
the proliferation of newsletters in the
number of companies that
are willing to buy them we saw a morning
we saw the hustle we saw
there was one more well i'll say look
sam got paid but sam got paid after
austin and alex and morning brew got
paid
and we just got online they're all
getting paid that's good
i like them i like when my friends win
sam got paid austin got paid alex got a
newsletter
trend of the action it's marketing
that's what they're doing these
companies are realizing hey
they have eyeballs if i want to reach
those eyeballs then i'm going to buy
this asset
and then i'm going to just sit there and
i'm going to send my information to the
people
that was the other one robin hood bought
market snacks that was the first one
then morning brew then the house
robin hood didn't have any benefit of
that email it didn't really help them
yes they did didn't save them from
shutting the markets off but go ahead
so i remember back in like 2016 people
were like
oh it's you know newsletters are over
we're peak newsletters and now
like there are so many newsletters that
shows that that was not the peak
and there's still room for innovation i
agree
i just think anytime that you can
coalesce ooh
big word for you all fools i don't think
you're get coalesce attention
in one communication channel then
somebody gonna come
pay you for it because everybody wants
attention they want
distribution and that's what these guys
all had you gonna sell the pump
newsletter i
saw nothing ain't nobody got enough
money i saw
nothing stop coming and asking all these
stupid ass questions all these
media companies all call me mm-hmm
that's cool you want me to rattle the
names off
yeah because you know i'll do it they
all called i think
i talked to him i listened
nah unless you put my name unless you
put my name on the business card
and not in the name field i wanna pop as
the name unless you wanna pay him an
endless lifetime supply of dominoes and
mcdonald's you ain't gotta well if you
if you
got that we could if we have a little
conversation in lifetime supply i mean
like i eat a lot that'd be the big boy
number but i ain't saying that
y'all fools ain't got enough money ready
unless your satoshi call me
satoshi hit me up spotify record
spotify recorded a doubling and podcast
listening hours in the fourth quarter of
2020
as locked down listeners hunted for
entertainment
and they are attributing it uh so the
audio streaming company which now has
155 million
paying customers saw its total monthly
user base including those on the free
advertising supported tier grow 27
year-on-year to 345 million basically
they're saying that they're
they're crediting the podcast popularity
for 24
growth in subscribers to be honest
i'm shocked at how slow they're growing
really
they got they spending all this money i
got joe rogan they've always seen 24
years old yeah 25 that's it
four percent no year over year oh wait
did i say 25 yeah
it's like 24 25 27 whatever i mean look
it's not a big number it's 300
but they only got 300 million people
only i mean
again let's keep it all in perspective
that's a lot of people
right but at the same time like 25
year-over-year growth it's like let's go
let's get it cranking there's a lot of
people on the internet more than 300
people
they basically got the united states on
that's that's basically three hundred
thirty three hundred times
it's a lot but it's a global business
let's
go let's get it cranking if you're gonna
go spend all that money you got 25
growth what i would expect to see is an
increasing
rate of growth that is exactly what i
would expect too let's move on
and look she mad shop if i don't eat or
uh spotify don't even call me
what i appreciate daniel eck is a genius
he's super smart
i really like daniel he works hard
underrated ceos in my opinion well he
runs spotify i don't know if he's
underrated but
i think he's not given as much credit as
he should be that's probably fair
but still don't call me yeah i think he
was planning on calling you
how you know maybe i talk to them
okay mckenzie and company the concern
the consultant to blue chip corporations
and governments around the world
has agreed to pay nearly 600
million dollars to settle investigations
into its role in helping turbocharge
opioid sales
a rare instance of it being held
publicly accountable
for its work with clients wow
i mean guess what
these drug dealers were putting drugs
in people's bodies and they were finding
all sorts of stupid
economic incentives to do it and they
had the help of a consultant
you tell me if pablo escobar went to
mckenzie was like yo will you work for
me
they'd be like no but all of a sudden
when these clients show up and they all
like will you
uh work with us they're like yup no
problem let's go stuff opioids into
mirror do you think it's because it's
more of like a white
collar drug than um
or like operation than like pablo
escobar would be
people in this situation i don't know
who knew i don't know if mckenzie
if uh other people if uh purdue pharma
whatever but people knew
that there was folks dying and they kept
doing it
i ain't cool with none of that it's
really cool all they are are drug
dealers with cologne
that's it with their drug dealers and if
you're a drug dealer
okay by the way if you want to do plants
you want to do marijuana
like yourself out you want to do uh
ayahuasca
for yourself you want to do psychedelics
nobody is
you want nobody is promoting drug use on
this show
it's not why you're a citizen do
whatever you want
she's she literally is sitting
underneath the table she's hitting me
under the table told me to stop
we should legalize marijuana okay
mckenzie
you in trouble it says it says that
documents show how mckenzie worked to
drive sales of purdue pharma's oxycontin
painkiller
amid an opioid crisis in the united
states that contributed to the deaths of
more than 450
000 people over the past two decades
that is absurd
opioids killed more people than
coronavirus
facts okay two decades one year
true calm down true okay thank you she's
not happy with me but that's okay
i'm just saying i have a very as many of
you know who have watched the show for a
while
the one thing that i have a lot of
sensitivity around is that when
businesses take advantage
of people especially when they know what
they're doing especially
especially whatever but i ain't selling
go ahead
okay uh no no
no don't you guys think that she's so
perfect this is truly the worst episode
but we're just gonna power through it
it's gonna pop with these watch because
people want the truth people want the
truth go ahead
by the way people i appreciate you and
thank you for watching this every day
they watch because of you
okay i ain't selling though
are you done this is one of those
awkward moments
where everyone's like he's gonna get
murdered today
are you done thank you
come on let's go hey whoever this is who
knows that's that's the name of the
person who knows
we don't know who you are but also pro
tip if you're the person who's tagging
us in the car you can't tag on youtube
chill out what resources do you use to
vet
research projects people or companies
you may invest in i assume you speak to
those you invest in but the question is
specific to the vetting process before
initiating contact oh i'm a
i literally like i can dig up some stuff
like i can you think the fbi is good
i can find things that you were thinking
when you were 13 years old
are you on uh kids websites
wait what no i just i'm really good at
digging up information
uh i just talk to people i don't do a
lot of research they said
before you talk to the company how do
you do i don't look i just
let me talk to the pro who who's in
charge here that's my favorite question
who's in charge and are you selling
actually i don't like to
sound like i don't invest i don't invest
in companies if they tell me they're
going to sell
i i'm not interested this is anthony's
karen moment
who's in charge who's in charge and are
you gonna sell
to the manager i don't like when people
sell because if they sell it means they
sold too early we don't sell
we go public we don't sell we go public
if i'm invested i want to go public i
don't want to sell
selling's like it's like getting on the
roller coaster and you got a two-minute
roller coaster you get
45 seconds the end of the road always
talk about not selling if you ever sell
good luck because the people
if i sell listen i'll tell you right now
if i ever sell
you guys gonna know one thing
me and sam got paid that's what you're
gonna know that's the only time i'm ever
gonna stop but nobody got enough money
ain't nobody got enough money
i literally one time sat in on a meeting
where somebody was trying to
add no somebody who's trying to buy the
newsletter or something it was
trying to advertise advertise i know
what you're talking about
yeah but i thought that there was a
negotiating they were negotiating and at
one point the other guy said
why don't you just come work for us and
he said you ain't got enough money
and the guy was like whoa and i knew how
much money they had and they had a lot
of money and
he ain't got enough money and he was he
was real upset a very uncomfortable
moment in my life
uh emmanuel sometime i say it on youtube
i'll say to his face whatever
emmanuel hey guys big fan here ask
pimp to reevaluate her be kind to your
friends line it's easy to be kind to
your friends perhaps we should focus on
being kind to people who don't know
and people that don't like us i think
that's a very good point
i like emmanuel you know why because he
ain't taking your [ __ ]
yeah but you see how i had to try to be
nice today and
to my friend who was driving me crazy
driving me crazy listen
crazy is a personal state that's a
personal problem if you want to be crazy
you can go be crazy if you don't want to
be crazy stop being crazy like it's easy
is that the end of this i'm not ready to
leave though no no no no
i want to hang with the people today you
know why i want to hang out let me
explain something
congratulations congratulations to sam
parr
and the people at the hustle you guys
work very hard somebody even said you
hustle
congratulations on the sale no problem
if anyone out there would like to talk
to me i don't want to talk to you
i'm not selling sam sold so sam got paid
i'm proud of him
i'm proud of the people who work at the
hustle my wife is mad at me so if i just
continue
talking about this for long enough then
she'll eventually calm down there it
wasn't
we'll see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends